[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt in meinem heutigen video möchte ich
euch einfach so ein bisschen ein
einblick geben in unseren alltag genauer
gesagt in unseren neuen alltag momentan
sind wir wirklich alle zu hause die
kinder haben schulfrei die kitas und
kindergärten haben geschlossen
das heißt die meiste zeit sind eltern
mit ihren familien zu hause dürfen oder
müssen lehrer zu hause spielen die
schulaufgaben erledigen die kinder
beschäftigen und es ist wirklich für
alle eine ganz neue situation vor allem
weil man eben zu hause ist in seiner
familie mit seiner familie aber
irgendwie auch fremde menschen oder auch
freunde die großeltern nicht treffen
darf und es ist für alle ganz neu aber
ich würde sagen das ist eine schöne neue
situation eine chance und es ist einfach
ein ganz neuer tagesablauf und ich zeige
euch heute in diesem video wie wir
gerade unseren tagesablauf meistern was
wir machen was es für tipps und tricks
gibt wie er die kinder beschäftigen
könnt und wie ihr trotzdem als pärchen
oder auch als einzelperson nicht zu kurz
kommt bei uns ist es so wir arbeiten ja
sowieso zu hause das heißt hier haben
wir einfach unsere wohnung sozusagen um
auf der anderen seite der garage haben
wir unser küchenstudio unserer küche in
der wir unsere youtube filme drehen
unser dreh alltag hat sich im prinzip
nicht verändert der einzige unterschied
ist wie gesagt dass die kinder von
morgens bis abends zu hause sind und
eben mit uns den alltag verbringen
wichtig ist jetzt momentan nicht einfach
die zeit zu verbringen sondern die zeit
sinnvoll zu nutzen
das heißt wirklich schöne momente mit
euren kindern erleben schöne momente mit
eurem ehepartner erleben aber auch zeit
für sich selber zu finden
das ganze kann man sich so vorstellen
wie eine art pyramide ich kann ich das
thema aufzeichnen
dass sie ist sozusagen die zeit pyramide
als ihr habt hier die pyramide
und die ist jetzt bei uns zumindest auf
drei aufgeteilt denn wir sind eine
familie mit kindern hier ganz unten das
ist wirklich der größte tat
das ist die familienzeit dicht gefolgt
und nicht zu vernachlässigen die
parkzeit und da folgt auf der spitze des
turms und ich weiß es kommt bei den
meisten zu kurz die ichzeit man sollte
sich selber nämlich auch nie vergessen
das heißt hier bin ich alleine hier mit
meinem partner und hier eltern mit kind
ob es eins zwei oder drei oder noch mehr
wir sind prinzip egal und diese zeit
pyramide dies nicht nur jetzt wichtig
jetzt wo ihr alle zu hause seit sondern
eigentlich in eurem ganzen alltag immer
wichtig ihr solltet wirklich immer
genügend familienzeit mit einplanen
und damit meine ich auch gezielt
familien zeit also schön zeit mit ihren
kindern verbringen mit ihrem ehemann
zusammen oder ehefrau zusammen fahrzeit
das heißt ohne kinder auch mal die zeit
zu zweit verbringen und natürlich die
ichzeit was macht euch persönlich spaß
und damit meine ich jetzt nicht alleine
das bad putzen alleine kochen sondern
wirklich alleine was für sich tun was
ich in der zeit zum beispiel gerne macht
lesen oder ein bisschen sport momentan
darf ich eben nicht ins fitnessstudio
aber dafür kann ich dann auch zu hause
ganz isoliert was machen und vor allem
wenn ich die ich zeit habe kann es
einfach auch sein dass der buch hab dann
gerade auf die kinder aufpasst und wenn
ich dann eben keine ich zeit habe
sondern der murat passt ich eben auf die
kinder auf also das könnt ihr euch
wirklich richtig schön einteilen
[Musik]
was momentan für uns alle das wichtigste
ist ist dass der tagesablauf
strukturiert ist also nicht einfach so
in den tag hinein leben können sie auch
machen aber es wird auf dauer sehr
schnell langweilig und vor allem geht
man sich dann vielleicht irgendwann
wirklich tatsächlich auf die nerven
das heißt ich plane den alltag für uns
alle nicht so konsequent wie es in der
schule in der schule übernehmen das ja
die lehrer die stunden der
schulunterricht der stundenplan
zu hause habe ich jetzt hier für samira
auch einen wochenplan und das machen wir
dann wirklich von woche zu woche
wir haben von der schule auch ganz viele
aufgaben bekommen die sie jetzt in der
zeit erledigen darf und ich hab das
ganze hier aufgeteilt von montag bis
sonntag samstag und sonntag darf sie
natürlich freizeit machen einfach
wochenende und lesen und kopfrechnen
machen wir sowieso eigentlich fast
täglich und alle anderen aufgaben habe
ich jetzt hier schön aufgeteilt im
schulwochen solltet ihr wirklich auch
machen und mit dem kind zusammen auch
gerne durchplanen denn so weiß euer kind
was zu tun ist kann natürlich auch
selbst direkt mitbestimmen ältere kinder
können das vielleicht sogar auch schon
selber machen und samira bekommt dann
hier diesem wochenplan und kann wirklich
aufgabe für aufgabe abarbeiten und
einfach dann auch schön markieren und
mit einem häkchen versehen denn dann
weiß er was er schon erledigt hat das
ganze motiviert natürlich auch ungemein
und rzb ds4 jahre alt seid jetzt auch
kindergarten frei aber hat jetzt keinen
stundenplan
die l macht aber trotzdem hier auch ganz
gerne mit das heißt morgens ist für uns
so die schulzeit samira erledigt die
schulaufgaben ella spielt dann schule
das heißt sie mal sondern ein bisschen
oder versucht schreibübungen zu machen
oder sie tut so als witzig etwas lesen
samira macht ihre hausaufgaben
größtenteils alleine aber natürlich bin
ich trotzdem als ansprechpartnerin da
oder erkläre was wenn sie etwas nicht
versteht und er lag kann auch ganz
alleine lernen und hat auch so ein
bisschen beschäftigungszeit für sich
alleine
sie nutzt nämlich dann auch ganz gerne
die youtube kids ab da gibt es nämlich
auch ganz ganz viele tolle lernvideos
das heißt sie kamen zb das abc lernen
oder zahlen
wir schauen auch super gerne englische
lieder an oder hören sie an
so kann sie auch schon mal den
englischen wortschatz ein bisschen üben
und über die youtube hit sap weist sie
einfach was sie alles anklicken darf da
gibt es oben einfach dieses feld lernen
oder entdecken oder auch musik hören und
serien schauen und wenn ich sage keller
kommen wir so ein bisschen schulzeit
leyen doch ein bisschen was kann sie
einfach in der app ihre inhalte
aussuchen oder ich suche er aus und dann
darf sie das gerne anschauen und das
macht sie auch wirklich total
selbstständig und verbringt so einfach
ihre zeit auch schön alleine
[Musik]
komme
alles erledigt dann geht doch wieso
spielen oder was möchte jetzt machen
basteln spielen mit hopkins ja
[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben herzlich willkommen bei
tobi lotter ach wie süß ja auch ich habe
euch alle vermisst und um ganz ehrlich
zu sammeln
[Musik]
nach lotte ich weiß sie ist es
langweilig aber ich benutze übrigens
grad verschiedene art und weise mir zum
lernen zum einen hat er natürlich ihrem
schulstoff den see hat es gibt aber auch
viele kinder die in der schule nicht so
viele hausaufgaben bekommen haben so
miraß freundin zum beispiel die nutzen
auch viele online plattformen zum lernen
zum einen gibt es da plattform wo man
einfach kostenloses unterrichtsmaterial
bekommen zum anderen nutzt samira aber
auch zum beispiel die youtube app zum
lernen da kann sie sich nämlich mathis
spiel songs anhören oder einfach
verschiedene dinge lernen geschichten
anhören und die nutzt sie auch ganz
gerne vor allem kann sie dann schauen
was jetzt gerade lernen möchte ob sie
zwei kabeln sind oder englisch wörter
oder englisch sorges oder ob sie
wirklich das einmaleins lernen will
da schaut sie danach kann lernen und das
ganze ist dann eben spielerin manchmal
mangelt es einfach nur an einer methode
und genau das will ich mich würde zeigen
ich zeige euch mal wie ich meinen
schülern das einmaleins beibringen was
ich den eltern erklären
und warum das aus meiner erfahrung den
letzten zehn jahren wirklich einen
großen erfolg hatte
also geben wir es gemeinsam durch da
drin steckt auch gleichzeitig die
geteilt aufgabe den sechs geteilt durch
sechs ist 1 seht ihr es einmal sechs ist
6 und 6 geteilt durch sechs ist 1 also
nicht so stur und stupide auf dem platz
sitzt sondern was auswendig lernen
sondern wirklich spielerisch teilweise
mit musik begleitend und das macht ja
auch wirklich super viel spaß
jetzt kommt für uns unsere spielzeit
gerade für die kinder ist jetzt ganz
wichtig zu wissen ihr habt jetzt
spielzeit entweder gehen sie jetzt nach
draußen oder sie spielen in ihren
zimmern und die zeit kann man echt auch
ganz gut nutzen entweder als familien
zeit also als gemeine gemeinsame
spielzeit oder man kann es auch als ich
zeit nutzen also dass die kinder jetzt
auch wirklich die zeit haben mal zu tun
und zu lassen was sie wollen nichts
vorgeschrieben bekommen
und auch die elf jahre alt ist oder die
samira mit ihren fast zehn jahren
braucht natürlich auch eine echtzeit und
muss einfach ihre zeit auch selber
einteilen dürfen das heißt sie kann
jetzt entscheiden ob sie spielen will ob
so etwas lesen will ob sie basteln oder
kreativ sein will oder einfach die musik
anschmeißen und mit tanzen will
das kann hier wirklich jeder für sich
selbst entscheiden
murat wird es gleich mit dem kids nach
draußen gehen in den garten
die wollen nämlich jetzt noch streichen
das heißt wenn ihr jetzt gerade sowieso
zu hause seit könnte die zeit auch ganz
gut nutzen um dinge zu tun für die
normalerweise im alltag wenn ihre zur
arbeit geht lisa viel zeit ist aufräumen
ausmisten streichen renovieren
reparieren und all die anderen schönen
dinge
[Musik]
jetzt hast du wir gucken im alltag immer
schon dass wir viele gesellschaftsspiele
spielen skipper stürmer mit samira ganz
gerne lernt auch gerate und wir spielen
es eigentlich schon jeden abend
normalerweise auch mit oma und opa immer
jetzt momentan nur zu viert memory
spielen wir ganz gerne als es gibt
wirklich ganz viele tolle spiele die man
zu hause spielen kann probiert wegen ich
auch jeden tag zu spielen das macht echt
super viel spaß herrschte aufzupeppen
hallo
sie hat dieses jahr einstecken also da
könnte wirklich mit eurem schrank
schauen was wir noch alles so an spieler
habt hallo hallo und wir zeigen wir euch
gleich noch ein kreatives spiel wäre das
mal spielt
wieso muss sie mit ihr spielen die kann
man über mich erzählen doch kann sie
eben zeit mal wieder zählen kannst noch
ein test noch okay so stabil
die steuer identifikationsnummer ist
kann die sache auch nicht erklären das
immer noch nicht schreibt nicht nur
applikationen sag mal wechselt sind ich
sie kann zumindest zu den zahlen auch
was sind das für sie kann zur ministerin
zwar noch tanzen gl
[Musik]
was übrigens auch ein ziemlich cooles
spiel es dafür braucht ihr nur ein stift
und zettel oder sogar im ipad unterwegs
können das nämlich auch spielen machen
wir auch normalerweise gern im auto zb
also irgendein fach stift und der eine
krittelt was drauf was einfaches
irgendwie so jetzt bekommst du das und
kann sich das blatt drehen und wenden
und dann schaut sie was sie sieht und
malte das bild sozusagen fertig also was
richtig kreativ ist was siehst du ich
hab was
[Musik]
man sich auf dem ipad auch ziemlich cool
weil dann kann man auf ein und derselben
kritzelei mehrere bilder machen als auch
sowieso challenge gerta sie kreativ
tätig und man kommt dann auch rein also
es wird von mal zu mal immer kreativ und
abgefräste ich wieder dran
ich würde da dran okay wir hatten da
schon alles möglich
wir gucken auch mal zusammen das könnte
michael zwei monsterwellen sein und da
drin ist ein 12
[Musik]
das ist cool für anja hast du mein handy
geklaut gemacht
okay man muss auch dazu sagen dass man
machen kann was ich jetzt momentan auch
sehr wichtig finde vorallem wenn ihr
gerade viel zu hause seid solltet ihr
wirklich auf die mediennutzung der
kinder achten also lasst jetzt nicht
einfach wahllos vor dem fernseher sitzen
und fernsehen schauen den ganzen tag
sondern beschäftigt sie lasst sie sich
selbst beschäftigen sie können lernen
sie können spaß haben
aber was ich wirklich ganz toll finde
ist wenn man so wirklich vom fernseher
park denn im fernsehen kann man zum
einen nicht entscheiden was genau wie
viel sie schauen und vor allem kommen da
einfach die ganze zeit werbeblöcke und
ihr kennt vielleicht also das ist auch
schon erlebt dass die kinder dann
einfach die werbung mit trainern und
einfach dann zu viel geschaut haben und
wenn ihr die kinder schon an die medien
las dann wirklich gezielt deswegen haben
wir auch die youtube geht's runter
geladen
da kann ich nämlich für beide kinder
einfach profile erstellen sondern ihr 18
jahre alter eben vier jahre alt die
beiden haben natürlich auch verschiedene
interessen sie können dort lernen sie
können spaß haben sich aber auch mal
serien anschauen und ich kann das ganze
auf zeit limitieren
und wenn ich möchte kann ich sogar
profile oder kanäle die ich persönlich
einfach nicht so schön finde auch
blockieren das heißt sie sehen wirklich
nur das was ich möchte und so lange wie
ich es eben eingestellt habe und so kann
man den kindern einen gesunden
medienumgang beibringen sie ein bisschen
heran tasten lassen klar lassen wie sie
auch mal ans handy und lassen sie dann
eben auch was anschauen auch gerade so
ein bisschen runterfahren
sie können sich da hörbücher anhören
und also die haben da wirklich eine ganz
große anzahl an dinge die sie tun können
und ich habe trotzdem die kontrolle
darüber
und die kinder sind eben auch mal ne
zeit lang beschäftigt ohne dass sich
selbst beschäftigen muss am abend
schauen wir uns dann auch den sandmann
an wenn was im fernsehen verpasst haben
und vor allem können wir uns so dann
einfach die folge selber aussuchen und
samira hatten etwas größere medien zeit
als ella weil sie eben schon älter ist
sie lernt ja auch damit und bastelt fiel
damit und die lg darf einfach nicht so
viel schauen weil sie eben noch das
kleinere und jüngere geschwisterkind ist
[Musik]
am sa
meine hände sind verschwunden
ich habe deine rennen
da sind die hände
[Musik]
meine sind verschwommen
ich habe keine ahnung
[Musik]
ich habe meine community übrigens heute
morgen auch gefragt wie beschäftigt ihr
dann eure kinder was macht dir gerade zu
hause
jetzt schauen wir uns mal die antworten
okay ich bin echt gespannt
einige sich gemeldet guck mal
brettspiele puzzles backen basteln lego
spielen in wacken ist immer so ein
cooles thema will da lernen die kinder
wie soll ich sagen
selbständig zu sein selbst schlechte
werte die verletzte stelle zu arbeiten
ja man sollte nur den gesunden ausgleich
finden zwischen backen und kochen und
gesunden rezepten ansonsten werden wir
alle kugelrund kurzstrecke mit der arme
hund muss ständig spazierengehen malen
und backen
ich lasse ihnen die langeweile das ist
übrigens gar nicht gar keine so wie
jemand mal ja auch kinder haben sich
meine langweilen das ist das was ganz
ganz normal ist man musste ich noch voll
unterwegs sein um was machen oder das
ist ja mal lang mal wenn auch sehr
langeweile entsteht nachher etwas
kreativität hat ich weiß amira zumindest
bei ella entsteht immer irgendwie diesem
ihrer mutter über kreative die ela
da entsteht bin immer ruhig ist ihr
wisst ja selbst weniger kinder habt dann
ist stille nicht immer toll also die
letzten drei male als ella still war und
lange zeit alleine war waren drei
lippenstifte kaputt die waren komplett
überall level aber da hinzuschauen sie
immer ganz oft macken gestaltet und das
auch cool ist ein filmabend das ist auch
richtig cool mal paar einfach sich
popcorn hinrichten in so ein coole
filmabend kids zum kinoabend zu machen
das saugen richtig cool und da dürfen
auch mal chips da sein
das stimmt was wir momentan auch schön
mit kindern machen könnten
kresse einpflanzen also entweder nimmt
ihr ein bisschen watte und kresse samen
und können es einfach in kleine schüssel
machen
der mann lag noch was richtig cool ist
guck mal was steht da drauf für mehrere
einfach mal die fresse halten hat uns
der christian mitgebracht guckt machen
und das sind so kleine beutelchen drin
da war eben schon einer das kann man die
presse schon einpflanzen und dann wächst
die und jeden tag können wir dann die
kresse beobachten ok einfach so erde
rainha die kann man auch nach draußen
pflanzen oder drinnen aber wie gesagt
ohne erde geht es auch ganz gut dass
noch die samen drin
[Musik]
so und jetzt hier nehmt euch mal die
presse in die hand lieber ein bisschen
[Musik]
jetzt gießen guckt ganz wenig wasser ja
zu sagen okay marta hatte das hebe
hilflos und dann einfach beobachte und
essen auf butterbrot oder im salat oder
käse oder wurst brot ja
[Musik]
ob jazz zusammen und nachher muss es so
aussehen
ok so und wissen genau es ist ein kreuz
schätzt du bei einem talk guck mal da
mit und tragen hier sind sie drin die
trox jetzt du was passt genau
und das habe ich dann mal ganz kurz zu
da muss es nur zurückziehen ist es raus
sie ist raus so jetzt kann ich ein neues
rein machen jetzt rückt schloss 1 passt
und mach ich mal zusammen und genauso
braucht so ein zweites 3 und es macht es
auch gut es macht kurz alles alleine ok
just gefunden okay dann konzentriere
dich und mach das jetzt einmal ums
andere mal machst komplett alleine ok
genau du schaffst das ich lasse es nicht
alleine aufbauen schatz richtig cool
genau erst fixieren und dann anziehen
ganz so langsam aber schön machen ok und
immer alles sauber sowie mama du
schaffst das kommt lasst ihr schatz du
bist wie deine mutter ist echt ein
schlaues kennt das wenn es nachher
machen da wo ich nachher noch farbe und
da können wir das daher noch anstreichen
okay jetzt hats geschafft
klassische auch richtig schnell
so jetzt gleich raus und den kids wenn
ich verbringe mit den kids am tag und
wir bauen im haus zusammen wir machen
dinge wir machen den garten zusammen
sauber das könnte auch dazu aber wir
haben jetzt schon lange nicht mehr
gesehen ja und können immer gerade nicht
sehen und deswegen tun wir jetzt einmal
um mal kurz anrufen weil es endlich
daheim oder hallo
kuppe
[Musik]
da kommst du so und während ich mich
dann um die kinder kümmern kannst du
dich um dich kümmern
er wolle nur sagen viel spaß ja dass ich
zeit und ich habe jetzt nicht zeit viel
spaß viel spaß wenn ich ihn wenig wenn
ich in zehn heimischen wieder da bin
dann ruft die polizei okay
[Musik]
zumindestens 23 stunden am tag versuche
ich sie zum arbeiten zu bringen wenn ihr
wohnt ja auch kostenlos bei uns habe ich
recht also mich da auch was dafür tun
wichtig ist dass ich die kinder zur
selbstständigkeit zu bringen und sie zu
ermuntern und dinge selber zu machen und
vor allem ich bin handwerker und ich
will auch das handwerk wertschätzen und
dinge selber machen und die macht es
auch richtig coole samira ich habe es
jetzt einmal gesagt und die macht es
kommt mit alleine und dann hast du deine
eigene picknick bank mit dass michaela
zusammen oder
und gestern hat es wirklich komplett
alleine gemacht und die und die ella die
läuft herum
es ist ein werkzeug somit ist räder auch
einmal okay das ist es ja was ist das ja
ja ja also die ella weiß alle farben
schon und wie gesagt die ella ist dieser
miras handwerk nicht wirklich extrem
begabt wie ihre mama und die ella ist
halt ja die ist halt schlauer genau und
das haben wir erst haben wir diese bank
hier zusammen bei uns im umgang gemacht
weil es da nicht gewendet hat und das
sind farben auf wasserbasis also es in
acryl haben auf wasserbasis und mit dem
streichen macht dasselbe okay ich mache
das komplett alleine als auch das macht
jetzt die samira und wir gehen lieber
eine garten und ein bisschen arbeiten
okay okay du hast die untere seite
machen wenn diese amira fertig ist okay
ja das gab es alles zu machen aber jetzt
nach erstmal die samira ok und sondern
gehen wir in den garten und thun im
hochbeet masse heraus pflücken okay
und ihr müsst als alle wir helfen
arbeiten weil du zahlst auch keine miete
oder hast du vor miete bezahlt hast du
schon mal bezahlt ja schon nie bezahlt
ja du musst mir helfen jetzt dafür dann
kannst du sonst bei uns boden okay ist
es abgemacht hand drauf weil wir ja
[Musik]
ich habe dich ja ja wichtig
natur ist natürlich extrem wichtig
normalerweise ist opa natürlich jetzt
auch da und hilft uns hier draußen nicht
jeder hat einen garten ganz ganz klar
aber wir haben zwar auch ein weil deren
ehe machen zum beispiel mindestens
zweimal in der woche im wald spaziergang
und wichtig seine kinder auch zu zeigen
das ist es nicht eine birke das ist eine
eiche das ist ein nadelbaum dass den
kindern zu zeigen auch dass das erden zu
zeigen auch zu arbeiten arbeiten ist für
mich etwas extrem wichtig ist ich bin
jeden tag gern raus nicht arbeite viel
ich bin ein handwerker wie gesagt und
die die kinder sondern auch lernen die
schätzen dann viele viele dinge mehr
wert der weißen heutzutage den baum
entsteht wie ein baum wächst was dazu
alles nötig ist oder was ein nadelbaum
ist die ganzen holzarten und die kinder
wachsen hier auf die sich ganz ganz
wichtig und auch gerade in dieser zeit
ist es wichtig offen den kids
rauszugehen sie natürlich warm
anzuziehen ist es noch ein bisschen
frischen bisschen kalt aber das ist dann
drinnen kümmert sich die zelle um allem
drum und dran da dürfen sie auch ihre
ihre film gehen schauen und ihr zeug
machen ihre ehre ihre videos anschauen
wird was lernen mit der sally aber
draußen geht es um die in die wahre welt
sage ich mal so und da bin ich dafür
dass ich weiß auch nicht ob ich noch
einmal erzählt hat dass ich mehrere
handwerksberufe gelernt habe habe ich
schon mal erzählt dass ich eigentlich
offsetdrucker wind oder drucktechnologie
haben wir nicht wahrscheinlich sondern
eben sein doch vielleicht hat sie
verstanden
hilfst du mir was ist es deine coins
okay für die wollten nicht wie sie x
scouts sind das ist in der virtuellen
welt dieses geld sie haben mit ihren
grundfesten
woher weiß die sich vier mal was coins
sind was ist das was man sehen wo a
das sind 3 kunz die will ich alle haben
und übrigens alles meins gyorgy points
für mir ja wie ich gesammelt
okay wir können kein schnick schnack
schnuck ok schnick schnack schnuck
gleich nochmal schnick schnack schnuck
ich habe gewonnen einer gehört mir
nochmal 1 jetzt hat noch zwei okay
schnick schnack schnuck wiedergeboren
papier
nein noch einmal gehört auch mir ja ist
halt verloren noch mal schnee schnack
schnuck ich habe gewonnen gibt ihnen
auch noch hergibt
daher seien die muss fair sein das
spielen ich habe jetzt geworden ich habe
den letzten noch hatte doch jetzt noch
mal her du da stehen wir noch mal das
spüren wo alle ok da geht denn herkommen
so pech gehabt
gott ist jetzt doch nicht da hast deine
coins du brauchst du weinen kommt
[Musik]
also ihr seht ich habe jetzt auch gerade
keine ich zeit die ich zeit nutze ich
jetzt tatsächlich noch zum arbeiten die
ich zeit habe ich nämlich ganz gerne
wenn die kinder im bett sind oder
morgens ganz früh wenn sie noch schlafen
da hab ich nämlich einfach meine ruhe
und kann man den abend genießen auslesen
oder eine serie schauen oder eigentlich
nur dasitzen und eure kommentare
durchgelesen und jetzt was ich momentan
mache ist ich nehme gerade videos ab das
heißt ich schaue mir die videos an die
geschnitten wurden cook ob noch
änderungen da sind mache noch meine
rezepte fertig schreibt noch alles
runter und planen auch schon meine
nächsten arbeitstag und die kinder
werden jetzt gerade schon oder immer
noch von murat beschäftigt dass sie
streichen da draußen gerade den tisch
aller macht wahrscheinlich was anderes
so wie ich sie kennen als ich glaube
nicht dass er damit den tisch streicht
und wichtig ist dass ihr euch als eltern
momentan nicht den druck macht und sagt
ich muss mein kind auf biegen und
brechen den ganzen tag beschäftigen denn
wir haben momentan keine ferien und das
war jetzt alles auch so ein bisschen
nicht vorhersehbar was passiert keiner
wusste dass wir jetzt die nächste zeit
zu hause verbringen
die schwierigkeit ist eben auch die
kinder können jetzt gerade keine freunde
treffen aller hat keinen spielpartner dh
die zwei sind wirklich immer nur zu
zweit bzw zu viert mit uns oder in
seltenen fällen eben auch bei uns im
team
oma und opa sind nicht da als es schon
richtig große herausforderung und man
sollte aber auch wirklich den tag der
kinder nicht verplanen also die dürfen
ruhig auch mal langeweile haben kinder
müssen sich auch mal ganz alleine
beschäftigen aus langeweile entstehen
meist die besten ideen
okay auch der größte quatsch meist bei
energy stellt und wie immer was an
natürlich müssen sie beobachtet werden
und dürfen nicht alleingelassen werden
aber sie brauchen einfach ihren freiraum
und sich um sich zu entwickeln um ihre
hobbys zu entdecken die samira geht zum
beispiel gerade total auf in ihrer rolle
als köchin und bäckerin
also wenn ich ihr die verantwortung
übergeben samira mach doch mal das
frühstück falle oder sie kommt sogar
schon von ganz alleine auf die idee
steht morgens früher auf oder möchte das
abendessen für uns alle machen dann
lasse ich sie auch und jetzt könnte
wirklich gerade diese zeit nutzen und
sagen wenn ihr im alltag normalerweise
nicht zu zeit habt oder auch nicht die
geduld eure kinder
allein in der küche wechseln zu lassen
dann probiert es doch einfach jetzt aus
mir raus stellt sich dann hin schaut
sich videos an oder geht einfach in
meine app sucht sich ein rezept aus und
macht einfach klar muss ich am ende auch
noch die küche putzen oder nachputzen
bisschen mithelfen beim aufräumen
aber so kann sie zum einen lernen
verantwortung zu übernehmen wird
selbstständiger ihr hobby entwickelt
sich gerade also das hobby zum kochen
und backen sie hat wechselnde richtig
tolle leidenschaft dafür entwickelt und
es macht ihr einfach unheimlich viel
spaß sie ist beschäftigt und sie tut das
für die familie und das ist gerade etwas
richtig schönes
[Musik]
mit dachte sich da steht also
meerjungfrau bin so stolz auf die charts
ich habe noch nie vor einem leckeren
pfannkuchen gegessen bin so stolz auf
dich
kaka wachse die jetzt noch aus
dann esse ich sagen okay da ist an und
los geht's schon perfekt gemacht
[Musik]
das war heute so ein kleiner einblick in
unseren alltag der alltag der momentan
ein bisschen anders ist als sonst klar
wir haben jetzt jeden tag so ein
bisschen die gleichen strukturen also
morgens lernen dann die spielzeit und
daneben auch für jeden die zeit ganz
alleine
und bei allem was momentan passiert
lasst bitte eure kinder einfach nicht
spüren falls die ängste habt oder sorgen
habt wie es morgen weitergeht viele
werden jetzt vielleicht auch gerade in
kurzarbeit gehen und man weiß einfach
nicht wann die komplette situation sich
jetzt wieder entschärft auch bei allem
was passiert gebt euren kindern einfach
die sicherheit gibt ihnen die
geborgenheit die er ihnen sowieso immer
schon gibt also lasst sie einfach von
alldem nichts spüren aber seid trotzdem
transparent das heißt klärte kinder auf
warum können sie gerade um und opa nicht
sehen oder die tante nicht sehen und
warum kommen gerade keine spielfreunde
nach hause
das ist wirklich super wichtig dass man
sie aufklärt aber eben auch mit den
negativen dingen der welt nicht zu sehr
belastet also alles immer schön kindlich
erklären für uns ist der alltag jetzt
erstmal vorbei samira und ella spielen
jetzt gleich noch ein bisschen haben so
ein bisschen ist zeit für sich das heißt
sie vertrödeln ihre zeit oder spielen
was auf ihrem zimmer schauen sich eine
serie an oder lesen ein buch und dann
ist für uns der tag jetzt auch schon
wieder vorbei morgen geht es wieder von
vorne los das heißt ich achte jetzt auch
wirklich drauf dass die kinder abends
pünktlich ins bett kommen damit ich
einfach für morgen wieder fit bin dass
ich früh genug meinen feierabend habe
und die zeit im rat noch verbringen kann
oder eben auch mal ganz alleine
und das ist genau das was die elefanten
ton eines tages werden sie eine riesige
elefantenparade machen und sich alle
verkleiden alle nur nicht elmar days ja
schon kunterbunt und jetzt werden alle
elefantenbabys minute ecke und genäht
schlafen
gute nacht
erkennen
und wenn samira ihrer medienzeit hat
dann darfst du die youtube kids ab eben
auch benutzen willst dann ihr profil aus
und weil sie eben schon fast zehn jahre
alt ist und lesen und schreiben kann
sind bei ihr oben die reiter wirklich
auch schon ausgeschrieben das heißt sie
kann einfach wählen zwischen empfohlen
entdecken serien spiele oder eben auch
musik
[Musik]
nochmal seiten
jetzt sind die kinder im bett jetzt ist
passion seit
format
dann habe ich jetzt halt ich zeit
[Musik]